mesdames et messieurs mes chers
concitoyens le président de la
république a réuni aujourd'hui en fin
d'après midi un conseil de défense au
cours duquel ont été examinées l'état de
la situation sanitaire ainsi que les
projections les plus récentes sur la
diffusion du virus production réalisée
sous l'égide du conseil scientifique
j'ai conduit hier et avant-hier des
concertations avec les représentants des
groupes parlementaires politiques des
associations d'élus locaux et des
partenaires sociaux
il apparaît que si la situation
sanitaire reste mieux maîtrisée en
france que j'ai beaucoup de nos voisins
elle est cependant préoccupante près de
27000 de nos compatriotes sont
hospitalisés pour que vivent plus de
3000 personnes sont en réanimation et je
veux saluer une nouvelle fois
l'engagement de nos soignants la
progression des variants 10 anglais et
sud africain fait peser un fort risque
d'accélération de l'épidémie
la question d'un confinement se pose
légitimement compte tenu de ces données
mais nous en connaissons l'impact très
lourd pour les français sur tous les
plans
ce soir nous considérons au regard des
chiffres des derniers jours que nous
pouvons encore nous donner
une chance de l'éviter c'est pourquoi en
complément des mesures de couvre-feu qui
ont produit des effets réels mais
insuffisant nous avons décidé de prendre
sans délai les mesures complémentaires
suivantes toutes entrées en france et
toute sortie de notre territoire à
destination ou en provenance d'un pays
extérieurs à l'union européenne sera
interdite sauf motif impérieux
cela s'appliquera à partir de dimanche
zéro heure toute entrée en france à
partir d'un pays de l'union européenne
sera conditionnée à la réalisation d'un
test pcr à l'exception des travailleurs
transfrontaliers
tous les déplacements en provenance et
en direction de tous vos territoires
ultramarins seront également soumis
désormais à la production de motifs
impérieux à compter de ce dimanche les
centres commerciaux non alimentaire
d'une surface supérieure à vingt mille
mètres carrés c'est à dire ceux qui
favorisent le plus de brassage des
populations seront fermées dès lundi les
georges seront renforcés dans toutes les
grandes surfaces ont le poids qu'il en
coûte prêts garantis par l'état fonds de
solidarité chômage partiel s'appliquera
bien sûr pour pouls des salariés et des
entreprises concernées dans toutes les
entreprises où cela est possible le
recours effectif au télétravail devra
être renforcée à cet effet
une concertation sera conduite lundi
avec des partenaires sociaux pour en
définir les modalités
ce principe s'appliquera de la même
manière dans les administrations
publiques les policiers et les gendarmes
seront mobilisés pour contrôler le non
respect du couvre feu
l'organisation des fêtes clandestines et
l'ouverture illégale de restaurants dans
des proportions renforcer les dérives de
quelques-uns ne saurait ruiner les
efforts de tous une consigne de
particulière fermeté sera donc appliqué
pour ceux qui frodent
les règles en vigueur enfin dès la
semaine prochaine
notre stratégie tester alerté otg sera
amplifié
mes chers concitoyens plus que jamais
nous devons tout faire pour respecter
ses règles et celles qui nous permet au
jour le jour de lutter contre cette
pandémie respect des gestes-barrières
port du masque se tester et s'isoler au
moindre doute nous avons fait ensemble
nos meilleurs efforts pour accélérer la
vaccination est ce soir près d'un
million et demi de français ont reçu
leur première injection
notre devoir est de tout mettre en
oeuvre pour éviter
confinement et les prochains jours
seront déterminants
soyons très vigilants
mais ayant confiance car à chaque étang
les efforts collectifs et individuels
que nous avons faits ont été payants et
du fond du coeur je vous en remercie